you're like a sweet guy you told me you
sweetheart you didn't drink you didn't
drink really or smoke didn't drink I
didn't drink or do any drugs honestly I
I've never done anything like that and
so much so that the first time I ever
like got high I was like 36 years old
like I was like a grown man and a friend
of mine who like made like pot cookies
and would give them out to people and we
were everybody was gonna eat pot cookies
and then go to a party and but I can't
eat I'm allergic to eggs I have a very
severe food allergy to eggs so he was
like I'm gonna bring you the butter then
I make the pot cookies with cuz that's
got the butter you just eat some of that
it'll be the same thing as of you know
what I'm with my friends we're gonna
have a great night you're sitting
straight butter well I put it on safe so
everybody gets the cookies and it's like
much much much much much oh yeah I'm
these are delicious and I'm like I
spread some of the butter on a Ritz
cracker okay cuz I'm classy it's already
butter flavored it's a butter flavored
right and I'm just adding butter pot
butter to it I'm like much much much a
boom all right let's do this I'm gonna
get stoned yeah drugs and keep in mind
I'm a 36 year old man at this point um
and nothing happens like an hour later
everybody's like oh I'm so crazy hi oh
my god I'm like I feel anything slather
slather slather Ritz cracker number two
Oh God now we go to a party now hanging
out another hour has passed and
everybody's like crazy hi and I still am
not high at all boom boom boom are you
okay
do you know how this story it ends with
me dying no so I eat a Ritz cracker
number three covered in pop butter and
it then and then I go and I'm engaging
in the party and I'm talking with this
woman and I become inconsolably hot I
become like shatteringly high I become
like a version of high that is
catastrophic as far as I and and I have
this moment where I'm talking to this
woman and and we're catching up I
haven't seen her in a while a bit and
then at a certain point I just I'm like
and she kind of like checks up for a
minute looks at me and I'm like I am so
sorry I do not know what we're talking
about I recognize it's my turn to talk I
don't know what's going on I've become
very hot I can't be saying all things
that high people say and then realizing
that I've said them and then commenting
on them one of which was I just don't
know how long this has been happening
for time is moving in a way that I can't
even understand and she was like crying
of it that's like I know that sounds
like something a high person says but I
am really having a hard time